joe biden is done talking about
afghanistan the country that we spent 20
years building collapsed within hours 13
u.s servicemen were just killed in a
deadly terror attack by a new offshoot
of isis and according to reports the
biden administration willingly handed
over kabul to the taliban before we got
our troops out despite offers from our
old allies turned enemies turned to
allies again the taliban to let us run
the capital city through the end of the
month
people have a lot of questions
but we aren't getting any answers
because joe biden doesn't want to talk
about it
so thank you very much and thank you
commissioner i i really think it all
works
i'm not i'm not supposed to take any
questions but go ahead mr president on
afghanistan i'm not gonna answer again
can you see if they're still in it
he's not gonna answer it he's not gonna
answer it's so disrespectful and if you
think that was disrespectful just wait
until you see what he did at the
dignified transfer of our fallen troops
just wait until you see what his
administration did before the fall of
kabul
our troops can't count on their military
leaders our military can't count on its
political leaders day by day it's
getting harder to tell our allies from
our enemies i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday from cynthia who says
what president ever has gotten up and
said they gave me a list of those
reporters to call on
and and i i just do what they tell me
are you serious yes we are series this
is what's happening now
people sometimes talk about donald trump
as a kind of
meta president you know or a meta
politician in that
he makes
obvious and conscious all the aspects of
politics that used to be hidden you know
he talks about them
he's very famous he said this he goes
look they want me to sign presidential
okay how's this am i do i sign
presidential now right and it's almost
like he's doing a stand-up comedy
routine about being president
that's all true i totally buy it joe
biden's doing the same thing he's just
doing it in in a s in a joe biden kind
of way but it's the same exact thing
where he says all right they gave me a
list of people to call on that it's true
that
in past administrations the aides will
say okay you know here can you call on
this focus on this person don't talk to
this person but it's never conscious and
for the now the past two administrations
and we're talking about both political
parties here it's like
the presidency itself is transforming
it's like we're it's like everything is
just unraveling and becoming so
obvious
now that's what's really conscious when
you are unconscious at night you're
probably going to want to be sleeping on
a helix bed he likes sleep has a quiz it
takes two minutes to complete it matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you why would
you buy a mattress that were made for
someone else does that make sense you
could get one that's made for you that
makes a lot more sense to me with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way that you
sleep they've got soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers
helix is terrific you don't need to take
my word for it helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq and wired magazine you go to
helixsleep.com
knowles right now take their two-minute
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life it ships for
free it's got a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free and then they'll pick it up if
you want them to but trust me you're not
going to need that helix is offering up
to 200 off right now all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep.com knowles that is
helixsleep.com
knowles for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
the flagrant disrespect from joe biden
throughout this entire ordeal
is
it's getting worse by the day
i i thought that his cavalier attitude
with regard to afghanistan with regard
to the terror attack with regard to the
fallen troops certainly with regard to
talking to the press i thought that was
bad
then they're at the the dignified
transfer these are the
the
servicemen who were killed in kabul they
are brought back in coffins flags draped
over their coffins
and you've got the president and other
members of the staff and lots and lots
of family members with their hand over
their heart
and joe biden checks his watch
so you've got you know he's standing
there next to his wife
dr jill have to
lieutenant colonel vinman you gotta use
his
phrase
his his proper title and
dr jill and then other members of the
staff and there is joe with with members
of the family
watching
he checks his watch and you can tell
that he wasn't doing anything else
because he does it in a way that's
really obvious but he thinks he's being
surreptitious in a way that people who
are a little bit older often do that
what's he got does he have a tea time
is he late for lunch
he's got his eyes closed during much of
this something tells me it's not because
he's praying i i
strongly think it's because just as he
does during press conferences just as he
does during meetings with foreign
officials
he
falls asleep he just he just fell asleep
during the meeting with with the new
israeli prime minister literally in the
oval office he just he start his eyes
start to shut and the israeli prime
minister is going on and on about the
great relationship with israel and there
is joe biden literally
asleep
in the chair
hours before that terror attack
on
last week on kabul
the army's top sergeant major sent out
an important
tweet an important message for the
military's priorities this is sergeant
major of the army michael grinston
who wrote quote
it's a photo of lots of like women and
but some are black and some are hispanic
and some are white and he says diversity
is a number
do you have people that don't look or
think like you in the room
inclusion is listening and valuing those
people hashtag women's equality day
reminds us we're smarter and more lethal
when we come together as an inclusive
cohesive team our values demand it
our servicemen deserve better leaders
than these clowns our citizens our
civilians deserve better than these
clowns all of these people should be
fired and probably banished to saint
helena
this is what our military is focused on
one getting more women into the military
warm women into combat yeah it's it's
inclusive and more equitable when we
send our women to be killed and blown up
in the middle east that that makes us a
better country doesn't it
doesn't it i don't think so
i think it makes us a worse country i
think it makes us a much worse [ __ ] i
think it makes us a sick country
that we think it is not only tolerable
but good to send our women
to be maimed and killed overseas by
terrorists and to fight our wars for us
i think that makes us sick in the head
and sick in the soul moreover moreover
he's saying diversity it doesn't just
refer to sex obviously it refers to race
when people talk about diversity what
he's saying is diversity when you have
people who don't look like you
and
the only way diversity is ever mentioned
is when we're talking about having more
black people or more hispanic people or
occasionally more asian people
in
some group
it could if you have an entirely white
team that's not diverse if you have an
entirely black team it's very diverse
now obviously neither of those are
diverse
in any serious meaning of the word but
diversity just means more in black and
hispanic people
listen to what he's saying he goes when
we're diverse
we're more lethal
what he's saying is that black people
are more lethal than white people if you
if you follow what he's saying to its
logical conclusion he said if you've got
a team of all white people that's that's
not sufficiently lethal but when you add
black people to it then it's more lethal
therefore the only conclusion could be
that that black people are more violent
than white people black people are
deadlier
than white people but if you said that
if you came out and you said yeah blacks
are much more violent than whites aren't
they
that would be that would be racist
wouldn't it
i think that would be racist but then he
says it but he's saying it like it like
it's good and he uses the words
inclusion and diversity and so it's
that's anti-racist or something
then beyond race you've got this idea he
said you know when you've got a team of
just men that's not lethal enough but
when you add women then it's more lethal
because because the only conclusion
would be women are more violent and
lethal and deadly than men which is
preposterous it's just not true
because women are not as strong as men
physically
they're just not
they're just not
but we we have to live in this pretend
world so when our operations collapse
because of political idiocy we're just
scratching our heads gosh i wonder why
maybe it's because of people like this
this sergeant major and general milly
and all of the other soon-to-be
pink-haired top brass at the pentagon
and our political leadership most of all
because we are viewing the world through
a lens of unreality surreality
fiction and delusion
is it any wonder
when in the real world our plans fall
apart
you know who's deadlier right now
than
you know lesbian women
trans what i don't know whatever the the
victim groups are do you know who's
deadlier the taliban the taliban they're
deadlier than even the taliban were two
weeks ago here's why we we talked about
early estimates from the sort of
equipment or of this sort of equipment
that the taliban stole
government doesn't want to release these
numbers but some watchdogs have been
here's what we got
22 174 humvees
we've got 155 mxx pro mine proof
vehicles
169 armored personal carriers that's
pretty spooky
42 000 trucks and suvs 64 363 machine
guns just machine guns just full like
pull the trailers rips
over 64 000 of those 8 000 trucks 162
000 radios 16 000 night vision devices
that's very scary
uh 358 530 assault rifles
so you're going to ban quote unquote
assault weapons that aren't even really
assault weapons from american citizens
and then you're going to give hundreds
of thousands of them to the taliban 126
000 pistols 176 artillery pieces then
you've got
33 blackhawks 33 mi 17 choppers 43 other
helicopters oh four c-130 transports
just gigantic massive transport planes
bunch of other planes too
that's who's deadlier right now
meanwhile
there's a report out now according to
the washington post says a left-wing
outlet talking about the left-wing
administration
none of this had to happen
because apparently
the taliban met with top u.s military
officials in doha
presumably political officials too in
doha and qatar
and offered to let the united states
hold kabul until the evacuation was
complete
so the taliban said look we're going to
take over the whole country but you can
hold kabul if you want until you leave
and then there's not going to be any big
worry
and the american military said no
the leaders not the soldiers obviously
this was a meeting with the head of the
taliban
so the united states didn't want to have
responsibility for securing kabul
so then
the taliban gave security for kabul to
the haqqani network the haqqani network
very
deadly dangerous terrorist organization
that actually the united states used to
fund through the cia
get to that in just a second
absolute madness so now the united
states doesn't run kabul kabul gets
attacked the united states soldiers get
attacked and serve as other servicemen
and
in response according to a report from
cnn now
biden is just flying planes and planes
of afghans over to the united states
many of whom don't have any
documentation whatsoever we don't know
who they are we don't know if they're
from a bad group we don't know if they
want to kill us
just flying them all over complete
botched job
when you want to get your blood flowing
again when you want to just quench your
appetite when you want to get a little
more iron in your blood
i would strongly recommend you check out
good ranchers did you know that over 80
percent of the grass-fed beef sold in
the united states
is actually imported from overseas
sometimes you'll see they'll they'll
have some kind of mealy-mouthed wording
about america or usa in the packaging
but it's not actually from america well
the good ranchers have traveled the
country our country this one on a
mission to help the american family by
working together with local farms and
ranches and shipping straight to your
door goodranchers.com is a safe and
convenient way to order your meat they
save your family money they help the
american farmer they've got great stuff
better than organic chicken kraft beef
they got t-bones fillet i love fillets
especially strips probably my favorite
cut of meat gourmet burgers had those
just about a week or so ago they were
absolutely magnificent and they're half
the price of online competitors you get
the steakhouse quality you deserve at a
price every family can afford go to
goodranchers.com to buy now or subscribe
today save 20 on each box of
mouth-watering meats subscribing brings
the cost down to less than five bucks a
meal plus right now you get an
additional 20 bucks off and free express
shipping if you go to goodranchers.com
knowles or use codenoles at checkout 20
bucks off and free express shipping
goodranchers.com knowles know where your
meat comes from with goodranchers.com
joe biden this according to cnn
you know the reason that i keep quoting
these left-wing outlets here is because
when a left-wing outlet is going after a
left-wing politician or policy
it carries more weight than when a
left-wing outlet is going against a
right-winger or when a right-winger is
going after a left-winger for that
matter a quote this is cnn arriving
afghans without paperwork prompt delays
and security challenges
some afghans fleeing their home country
have arrived in the united states
without paperwork amid the rapid pace of
evacuations according to two sources
familiar with the situation the approach
from the administration has been quote
get as many people on the plane as you
can and we'll sort out the immigration
visa stuff later
some people have landed with no
documents whatsoever creating a very
challenging work environment for the
officers cool what what could go wrong
right what could possibly go wrong
brings me to an important point on our
afghan allies what a lot of the talk
that you're hearing from
left-wingers and neo-liberals and and
the kind of squish conservative types
the
they call them neo-cons or the
imperialist types the ones who wanted to
stay in the middle east forever and
continue to bomb various muslim
countries and spread liberal democracy
all over the world you're hearing a lot
of talk about
our afghan allies
i'm going to take you on a little trip
down memory lane about our afghan allies
okay because i don't know that we can
really know who our afghan allies are
okay i appreciate people who have helped
the united states out over the years
there
in 1983 ronald reagan welcomed a group
of mujahideen afghan freedom fighters to
the oval office he pointed out that
these freedom fighters were fighting the
soviet union and said the united states
was going to support them
the united states funneled a lot of
money to these mujahideen freedom
fighters over the years in in no small
part through the inter-services
intelligence agency which is a sort of
state within a state in pakistan so
through the isi
and also in other ways we start funding
the mujahideen freedom fighters the
mujahideen freedom fighters defeat the
soviet union the soviet union leaves and
the
soviet union collapses shortly
thereafter at that point believe it or
not all these various mujahideen groups
all of these various islamist groups
that fought the soviets the godless
atheist soviets turns out they weren't
so great at forming a government
together so that plunges afghanistan
into four more years of civil war during
that civil war there were various groups
and even though there were three four
then five groups it turned out that some
of the people fighting didn't think that
was enough militants in the conflict so
they formed another group that other
group is called the taliban they did
that with the funding of
the isi and with the encouragement of
pakistan's isi okay
the taliban quickly all of the
not all but virtually all of the
taliban's original leadership by the way
were people that the united states had
funded in the original fight against the
soviets okay taliban takes over
afghanistan starts to rise during the
early 1990s and then 1996 declares the
islamic emirate of afghanistan okay they
rule for about five years they they with
the support of our allies in the isi
harbor osama bin laden osama bin laden
al-qaeda osama bin laden al-qaeda attack
the united states on september 11th the
united states goes in and deposes the
taliban the taliban then goes out and
retreats we obviously stay there for
about 20 years now
the taliban is coming back into control
so that they there were our allies in
our enemy they were sort of our allies
then our enemy then our allies again now
we get attacked by isis isis is a rival
islamic terror group they just attacked
us in kabul they're fighting against the
taliban now
they attacked us because the security in
kabul wasn't good enough the security in
kabul had been
given to the haqqani network as i just
mentioned the haqqani network was one of
the largest recipients of cia funding
during the cold war so then the kakani
network turned against us the isi and
the cia were funding the haqqani network
until the isi started paying the haqqani
network to attack the cia are you still
following me because i'm not i can't
follow me anymore because it's so damn
confusing you've got the afghan national
army which the united states had been
funding for 20 years that's the one that
just collapsed when the taliban walked
in but even the afghan national army
first of all was largely comprised or it
largely comprised fake soldiers ghost
soldiers who just existed on paper so
that people could get paid but they
weren't real people in real life there
was a
report from the special inspector
general for afghanistan reconstruction
it showed that 50 to 75 percent of
afghan national army soldiers were high
on drugs a lot of the time when they
weren't high on drugs they were offering
stealing things and in some cases
especially in 2012 they were killing our
own soldiers and their fellow afghan
national army soldiers
there was also we talk about how awful
it is that there are new sexual crimes
being perpetrated by the taliban as they
take over kabul well it turns out the
afghan national army the good guys our
allies were perpetrating huge amounts of
sexual violence through a practice
called baccabazi this was ritual called
boy play it was ritual heterastic abuse
of young boys there were well over 5000
reported incidents of this just to the
oversight authorities and almost
certainly the problem was much more
widespread than that so please please
when you're telling me about what we
should do in afghanistan please spare me
the sanctimony over our allies because
we have no idea who our allies are
because there are no allies in
afghanistan which is not a country
it's not a nation
and our allies change by the day
sometimes by the hour
so yes we all want to evacuate people
who are good guys who are on our side
who help us out and who want a vision of
the world that we do
but that's changed a lot over the years
okay
and i think this is wha people's
exasperation with our foreign policy in
afghanistan is that we have no idea what
we want because it it became
one
initially was this attack to go kill the
terrorists who took down the towers then
it became this this crusade for nation
building and spreading liberal democracy
and abolishing tyranny from the world
those are george w bush's words
and then it became what about sending
girls to school or something and that's
why we're going to keep our guys in
harm's way
what is it what is it a sensible foreign
policy asks
basic questions
what do we want to have happen there
now
what do we stand to gain from it
how much are we willing to lose
that's what we have to ask and all of
this clap trap
about our allies the wonderful amazing
out no look
there are no allies there are interests
in afghanistan okay
and the longer it takes us to learn that
lesson the worse off we're going to be
speaking of
allies that we can't rely on mitt romney
goes on cnn naturally he's talking to
jake tapper and he says you know this is
not really just biden's fault is trump's
fault too
leaving americans behind and leaving our
afghan friends behind who've worked with
us
would put upon us and will put upon us a
moral stain
and this is the result
of very ineffective decisions terrible
decisions made by the prior
administration by the current
administration this did not have to
happen it was it was preventable
and let me know that's very different
than the military our military came in
at the very last moment
and has performed admirably as far as i
can tell to move people out as quickly
as possible but we didn't have to be in
this rush circumstance with with
terrorists breathing down our neck but
it's really the responsibility of the
prior administration in this
administration that has caused this
crisis to be upon us and and has led to
what is uh without question a
humanitarian and foreign policy tragedy
notice what's missing from mitt romney's
attack on donald trump here
any specific allegation
any evidence
so he says look we didn't need to be in
this situation where the terrorists are
breathing down our neck yeah that's true
that's um
that's trump's fault trump's been out of
office for eight months
trump said we'd get out by may
this administration bungled that and
didn't get out until late august so now
we have the terrorists breathing down
our neck how's that trump's fault well
we didn't need to be in a rush 20 years
is it rush that's a rush to you mitt
romney
but what what romney has to do is say no
it look it's all everyone's to blame
it's no one's fault in particular and
when people say no one is to blame
nothing is to blame it's everybody it's
all everybody together
what he's trying to do is not change
anything
what he's trying to say is look no it's
everybody's fault don't hold anyone
accountable don't come to any
conclusions we really we just should
have stayed we just should have stayed
another 20 years or another 60 years or
another 80 years because mitt romney
a court jester conservative a clown
whose entire job is to legitimize the
liberal regime he is there
to just try to keep this whole thing
going but i think getting back to that
comment at the top of the show
the the liberal establishment is is
cracking under the weight of its own
incoherence and illogic we're seeing it
happen we're seeing this sort of fake
performative meta presidency in in joe
biden the presidency that always talks
about the presidency okay reveals all
the secrets of the presidency i'm going
to call on the people they told me i had
to call on the people i'm the president
or donald trump but yeah i got to sound
really presidential don't i
we're seeing it collapse we're seeing
the incoherence of our afghanistan
policy particular collapse in real time
and speaking of dishonest politicians
on cnn specifically dr fauci goes on cnn
on the same show he goes on
jake tapper's show
and he complains about people
attacking him this guy talk about
dragging out political operations we've
dragged out afghanistan for 20 years
we've dragged out the 15 days to slow
the spread for well over a year and a
half now and dr fauci says please please
stop attacking me right now you can
subscribe and start listening to morning
wire on apple spotify wherever you
listen to your podcasts leave a five
star review if you like what you hear
when you sign up for the daily wire
readers pass you get the news that no
other media outlet covers if you sign up
right now you'll get a free four week
trial you'll unlock exclusive access to
editorial content that just does not
exist anywhere else after the trial is
up the price is just four bucks a month
so sign up for your reader's pass at
dailywire.com subscribe right now hurry
because the four week free trial ends
tomorrow august 31st we'll be right back
with a lot more
dr fauci can dish it but he can't take
it dr fauci can lock down our whole
country for a year and a half he can lie
to the american people he can mislead
people on the efficacy of various
measures he can change his mind day by
day sometimes hour by hour but the
minute you criticize him all of a sudden
he wilts he says i'm not a politician
i'm a scientist why are you attacking me
whoever is attacking me and attacking me
just a reflection of the politicization
of what should be a purely public health
issue
and it's really unfortunate you know
they're attacking personally me
because i'm a visible person but i'm
merely articulating
the proper public health practices that
are
recommended strongly by an organization
and that organization is the cdc
so they like to pick out a certain
person because they could make that
person you know the personification of
political divides which is so
unfortunate jake we should put all of
that aside we have an extraordinary
problem that's killing people in the
united states killing us putting us in
the hospital so that kind of
politization that you just mentioned
there's no place for that when you're
dealing with a public health crisis
there's no place for politicization he
doesn't pronounce it correctly but
that's fine
that just shows you how little he
understands about politics and its
relation to public policy he says
there's no place for politicization
in public health
political
means public
public means political
public health
public health policy is by definition
political
dr fauci a public health expert
policy maker
is
by definition a politician he gets his
paycheck from the government he does
things that pertain to the public with
the support of the government and he's
outlasted
six pres he's on a sixth president right
now but he doesn't he doesn't even i'm
going to give him the benefit of the
debt i don't want to ascribe to malice
that which is explained by ignorance and
stupidity
thou she doesn't i even understand what
public health is
we have a problem jake we have a problem
of people dying here because of things
that are happening in the public right
here people are dying because of the
lockdowns people are dying because of
deaths of despair people are dying
because they can't get their urgent
medical treatment that is not related to
covid they certainly were at the
beginning of the lockdowns
and that's on you fauci and that's on
you i am merely a voice for the proper
public health measures
according to whom
because according to me look i'm a
citizen of the united states i'm i'm a
member of we the people who are
supposedly able to govern ourselves and
uh i don't think that your measures are
the proper public health measures i
think they're very improper
and according to the constitution i'm
supposed to have some say in that and
actually according to the constitution
you're nowhere to be found other than as
a private citizen who can vote i don't
see the cdc
in the constitution i don't see the
exalted dr fauci in the constitution
there are entities that have been
created and brought into the government
through the law-making bodies the
law-making bodies that were established
in the constitution over time and
they've been given extraordinarily
extraordinary powers that have
undermined the constitutional order
there's no question about that
but
as far as i can tell we still have the
opportunity to decide how we want to
live in our view but in fauci's view you
don't you don't you just need to go
along
people why are they attacking me
because
you've usurped our our power our
legitimate power as a free people that's
why and he doesn't even get it it's such
it's a joke to him he doesn't even
understand
what he's done which might be why we
don't
trust him to understand much of anything
else
speaking of the politics of the
coronavirus
you know i hate to say i told you so you
know it pains me i hate it it's hard but
i
i told you so
howard dean former presidential
candidate before he ye hud himself back
out of the 2004 presidential race
howard dean former chairman of the
democratic national committee
howard dean former governor of vermont
now just some guy who talks on msnbc
howard dean busted out a line that i i
told you months and months ago they were
going to do
he busted it out a little earlier than i
expected
he says you know that donald trump he
was bad
but he was nowhere as bad
as ron desantis
uh well i'm actually just shocked by
desantis i never thought i'd say this
but i think he may be more of a lunatic
than trump ever was i mean trump has
finally come around to understanding
that the best thing he can do for his
own supporters is get them to be
vaccinated desantis is just completely
out of touch with reality
oh desantis oh he's much he's like super
mega duper trump he's oh yeah
remember how
do you remember how for the past five
years or sit probably six years now
we've told you that donald trump is the
singular threat he is hitler he's unlike
any other republican ever how george
bush who we used to tell you was hitler
he george bush is great now and he's
good and he's a reasonable republican
and i've got a strange new respect for
him and all the other republicans well
sure i disagree with them but they're
fine but donald trump is the worst he's
a unique threat
he's hitler
you can't vote for him
so they they told you that for five
years
and and at the time i said you know they
don't mean this trump's fine he's
governing just like a like a normal
republican in many ways actually sort of
returning to a more normal republican
vibe like pre-bush era
but
they're just going to do it to the next
guy and the democrats assured me they
said no we won't michael i told this to
my democrat friends and relatives i said
you're just going to do it to the next
guy you're going to say the next guy's
worse than trump no we trump is unique
he's the worst ever i said no you're not
you're gonna find whoever it is
maybe that person is going to be i don't
know josh hawley maybe i don't know it
could be nikki haley it could be these
are various times in the administration
different characters were popping up a
little better it could be ted cruz it
could be ron desantis now whoever it's
going to be
you're going to tell me
that he is worse than trump or she is
worse than trump
and i was told no michael trump's unit i
think the left really believed it they
really believed the lines that they were
spewing that trump is this unique threat
but now ahead of schedule now we're not
this is 2021 still
we are already being told ron desantis
is much worse than donald trump he makes
trump look sane
and you know what's going to happen
let's say let's say the democrats are
obviously afraid of desantis right now
let's say desantis becomes the nominee
it's still very early to call that but
let's say he becomes a nominee let's say
he becomes president and then they're
gonna this is what's gonna happen
they're gonna call him hitler
for four years
or at least as long and it may perhaps
they impeach him and remove him from
office maybe he wins the second term
maybe it's eight years they're gonna
call him hitler
every day for eight years and they're
gonna say he's the unique threat and all
i miss the good old days of donald trump
and all the good old days of george bush
and all the good old days of ronald
reagan all of whom we called nazis at
the time and then if if desantis leaves
office and some other guy come they're
going to say desantis was the good guy
and the new guy's hitler that's the way
it works
do you get it yet do you see it i mean
this was this was my big problem with
never trump
or then what became in 2020 in the 2020
election the re-election they became
republicans for biden
republicans for principles
defending democracy and principles and
the evangelicals for biden evangelicals
for a million abortions a year
evangelicals for a debacle in
afghanistan the dignified adults
at the time i said
i don't know what your principles are
you don't seem to have very much dignity
and you don't realize it's just an op
this is just
propaganda it's just bs
trump actually is a very good president
but even if he weren't
he certainly is not the unique threat of
hitler
they didn't get it do you get it do you
get it now i think you probably do
some people are holding strong some
people who are more independent-minded
who are on the left or on the right i'm
thinking of joe rogan who at times is he
seems like a left-winger at times he
seems like a right-winger he was a
bernie guy but then he was a trump guy
he's not a biden guy he's not an
establishment guy
joe rogan's still holding pretty strong
we're now being told by the fouchies of
the world
and all of them that if you in any way
resist efforts to mandate the masks and
mandate the vaccine
you're a murderer you're a threat to
public health you're politicizing
everything
rogan's not hearing it
rogan is is holding a show at madison
square garden he sold a zillion tickets
already and now in new york they're
mandating the vaccine just like they are
in parts of europe
and so rogan faces this pro is he going
to
force his
fans many of whom have bought tickets
already to get the vaccine or
is he going to fight back
here's rogan's take
if someone has a
you know
an ideological or a physiological reason
for not getting vaccinated i don't want
to force them to get vaccinated to see a
stupid comedy show and i've already sold
13 000 tickets and now they say that
everybody has to be vaccinated
and you know i want everybody to know
that
you know you can get your money back i'm
not i'm not an anti-vaxx person right in
fact i said i believe they're safe and i
encourage many people to take them my
parents were vaccinated i just said i
don't think that if you're a young
healthy person that you need it their
argument was
you need it for other people so you
don't transmit the virus that makes more
sense so i'm a young but that's a
different argument
yeah and and by the way what joe is
leaving unsaid here at least in this
little clip is okay so now their
argument is you don't need it for
yourself because if you're vaccinated
you're totally fine and you know you're
not going to face serious consequences
of the virus and if you're unvaccinated
you're taking that risk but if you're
unvaccinated you're risking infecting
others
except that we are now told by the
studies by the science that the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated are
carrying similar viral loads that they
might not be as likely to face
hospitalization or death but they are as
likely to carry and transmit the virus
so then do you see the problem here for
the people saying you need to get vaxxed
for others
whether you're vast or unvaxed you may
very well carry the virus and transmit
it to others the thing that's going to
determine whether you go to the hot
whether anyone goes to the hospital or
dies according to the science according
to the experts according to the
politicians
is whether or not you have the vaccine
so it falls right back to this question
of personal choice
personal prudential judgment
what risk am i going to take as joe
rogan
correctly says
if you are a young person
you are at a very very low risk
of facing serious complications of the
virus if you're a morbidly obese 85 year
old
maybe you're at a higher risk okay maybe
you're gonna have a different
calculation
but if you're a young person the
arguments that the
the people who are mandating vaccines
are making don't make any sense they
don't make any sense at all and so rogan
hats off to him he's saying you know if
i don't i don't feel comfortable
mandating that my audience gets the
vaccine so you can have your money back
now eric clapton is going even further
than that clapton's saying he will not
play at venues because eric clapton had
the vaccine so he was open to it it's
not like he's totally anti-vaxxed he was
open to it he had a very negative
reaction we know the cdc and the fda
have told us that you can have negative
reactions to these vaccines there have
been to these vaccines there have been
multiple reported incidents of them and
clapton said yeah really paralyzed my
hands i couldn't play for a while so i'm
not playing
to houses that are mandating the backs
rogan is taking a sort of middle round
here and he's saying look i'll i'll play
i guess especially since we booked the
show before
the the city mandated this but i'm there
is no way i'm forcing my guys to get
this vaccine absolutely right
we are living in a world right now where
you can't trust the president of the
united states you can't trust the
military leadership they've all lost
their freaking minds you can't trust the
public health experts because they've
been wrong about a lot of stuff and in
some cases have lied to you you're
living in a world where joe rogan is a
much more credible person
than most of our elected and appointed
leaders
speaking of performances
olivia rodrigo olivia rodrigo is
apparently a popular musician i had
never heard of her until a month or two
ago when there was some story about
something she had done and i don't even
remember what she had done i apparently
she's a very popular musician has had a
bunch of number one songs and yet i
don't what do i know i'm not
this is not the sort of person that i
pay attention to
but i've now heard of her for the second
time and this is not because of any
music she's made it's because of
something she said
she said in a magazine interview quote
i sometimes get dms from little girls
being like
i've never seen someone who looked like
me in your position and i'm literally
going to cry like just thinking about it
rodrigo 18 said in the v magazine
feature i feel like i grew up never
seeing that also it was always like pop
star that's a white girl
so first of all this girl looks pretty
white i don't you know i guess she's
hispanic with a name like rodrigo but
she looks pretty white to begin with and
she's she's using this line that you you
constantly hear from the race hustlers
and and the victim people
and it says that you know growing up i
never saw oh she's filipi apparently the
producer is telling me she's filipino
okay whatever she just she looks
oh i wouldn't know she's ethnically
ambiguous let's put it that way but
apparently this is the defining feature
of her personality of who she is
and
she
comes out and says you know it's i never
saw people who looked like me and the
little girls today never see anyone who
looked like them
now some people are responding and
saying hold on lady um ella fitzgerald
aretha franklin uh hold on i pretty sure
we've seen some black popular musicians
or hispanic popular musicians before
and
or at least in i guess to go to her
example non-white popular musicians but
i want to be really fair
okay because she said pop star she said
pop stars were always white so yeah sure
maybe soul singers r b hip hop jazz
maybe they're black but
we've never seen non-white girl
pop stars right
so i took a little i just took a little
trip down google
looked up this girl olivia rodriguez was
born in 2003 apparently
2003 grammy for pop vocalist winner
norah jones indian woman grammy for pop
album goes to norman brown the black guy
grammy for pop vocal collaboration
santana hispanic and michelle branch
indo
2004 this is the next she's one year old
now pop vocalist christina aguilera
hispanic pop collaboration mary j blige
2005 nora jones wins a bunch again uh
indian woman including one with ray
charles who's a black guy 2006 this is
all in the pop category stevie wonder is
a winner de la soul is a winner black
guys
2007 christina aguilera is a winner
black eyed peas winner stevie wonder al
gero
for this girl's entire life
it has seemed if you're just looking at
the billboard charts and you're just
looking at the grammys
there is no reason for any
non-white girl to think it is
impossible
to become a big pop star if you're
non-white frankly
you would be more likely to think that
if you were a white girl during this era
you you might if you were a white girl
during this area you might look at the
pop shorts and think man a white girl
just can't make it in this world
this is not the industry for white girls
looking at but
but because
we are living in surreal we're living in
unreality we're living
in a delusion
right now
many people believe this
we are living in a delusion the white
house is living in a delusion the top
military brass is living in a delusion
all of us here in the culture are living
in a delusion
and delusions have consequences
because delusions run up against reality
sometimes
in kabul in the united states
and when delusions run up against
reality reality wins
and it's not it's funny i mean we can
make fun of rodrigo or who we can make
fun of mark milley you know the
pink-haired woke chairman of the joint
chiefs we can make fun of that sergeant
at sergeant major we can make fun of but
but there are real world consequences
here there's a virginia school district
right now
we're getting ready for the 20th
anniversary of the september 11th terror
attacks a virginia school district is
telling a teacher
they're telling not just one teacher but
all of their teachers to avoid talking
about muslim terror
virginia's department of education
the whole statewide department of
education hosted a speaker who
instructed teachers to exclude the role
that muslim extremism played in 9 11.
this woman amara de queer
who did a powerpoint called
education leadership
oh i'm sorry this woman is an
educational leadership scholar she
offered a powerpoint to these teachers
she said that teachers should avoid
using language that could pin those
events on muslim extremists quote school
and classroom 911 commemorations or
sites for ant for increased anti-muslim
racism
you see the problem even with just that
statement
muslim is not a race
islam
it's not a race it's a religion and it
is the religion
in whose name the terrorists took down
the twin towers
and it wasn't senseless violence and it
wasn't racist we now say all bad things
are racist it wasn't any of that
it was religious they had ideas and they
followed those ideas
to their logical conclusion they had
erroneous ideas
they had delusions and they followed
those delusions
into reality and it had really negative
consequences
before we go speaking of crazy teachers
can't i can't go a full day without a
libs of tick tock video
featuring a teacher who just came out as
non-binary
i'm about to come out to all my students
[Music]
so i have a quick announcement for
everybody can everybody look up from
their phones my class is important
please hello i'm waiting you guys look
at me
so i usually go by mr johnson but i
would like to be called zoa now my name
is zoa and i'm non-binary so you can
call me mr zola you can call me miss zoa
you can call me mixoa that's mx period
and i go by all pronouns that's it
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks guys that's it
oh thank you
the thing is though he's not nine
non-binary he's a man he's a crazy man
who should not be teaching children he's
living in a delusion he's encouraging a
whole generation of kids to live in a
delusion his own classroom but this is
happening at the national level too and
that delusion we all cheer it on now wow
i'm so proud of you you're you're
exploring your fantasies your delusions
those delusions are going to have
consequences and they ain't going to be
good i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles shall see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show